cross the country [ __ ] the intro dammit
are we live are we rolling now Kenneth
it's live hi hi hi I'm Mike Marty I'm
here with I'm one of the hosts of
resident Marrakech um we're gonna we
have played through the part more of
this resmio - we make like an ASM artist
no I don't like that stuff
hiyee people there's a lot of it on
Twitch we were talking about it the
other day on one of my streams and I
remember like it is odd because to each
their own right like some people like
listening to like mechanical stuff or
music that's like really simple like
lo-fi beats and some people like
listening to people like like like that
stuff I don't like that I don't I don't
get how the guttural chewing noises
could soothe anyone yeah Keep Watch the
showing up um don't like that yeah
you're not into that at all each their
own unless it's chewing noises to each
their own up when you listen to someone
chew what's wrong with you that gets you
to sleep then that's fine you feel like
you're just focused and Zen and do it
just don't just don't do it around me
yeah I also feel similarly I'm not as I
don't have the reaction you have but
I've certainly wouldn't listen to it to
go to sleep at night anyway welcome to
resident knievel we're playing through
every resident evil we've already played
through all the numbered series one
through seven and then we played some
bonus rounds like revelations and Code
Veronica and now we're going back
because Resident Evil 2 or least remake
so we are playing that remake this is so
technically this is my second
playthrough a Resident Evil 2 but my
first and Resident Evil remake and it's
quite different so far isn't it Mike
mm-hmm more in the stores now they
practically like got this art shop this
story is different the dynamics of it is
all different like they've changed
the whole feeling the whole vibe I don't
expect when there's a boss fight I find
it really good but playing the first
Resident Evil 2 did not prepare me at
all for what I'm going through right now
yes we ended last episode and you had
gotten the spark shot from the I got the
spark shot from that gross sewer area
and people are horrible to keep aiming
at someone after you shoot them and
it'll increase the damage you do okay so
you're saying hold l2 shoot it and then
keep my reticle on a monster and it
charges it more yeah it'll do like more
damage like a Taser I guess it's quite a
tip I don't understand how that works
but you know I'm no gun expert let's
check the old thing
and see what I got here I got two full
heels Oh three heels that's great
considering I am on coffee on I got two
new electronic parts which we could use
if you think or could I like plug them
in somewhere or do they have no value
right now and I should just store them
clogs no you you need all the plugs for
what could I like put them in here for
funsies or does that is that not how it
works yeah you could so it does have
some value or no yeah no yeah you should
put them in here but there is like if
there's that note to the right the rook
and the knight are on the same wall and
the bishop and Queen aren't next to each
other the Queen and the rook were
opposite each other too but how do I
even know where we begin is there there
are some notes on the there you go oh
that is all right let's see if there's
any other I think you're missing one
still that could be wrong great okay so
I have a queen and didn't it say
something about that
no the bishop Queen the rook and the
knight are on the same
what do I have I have a salmon yeah King
and I have a queen I think so
I don't think this actually helps me
which one is that
that's a mom that goes to the right oh
right
that makes sense
and then nights on the other wall I
think oh right you're right
you right you right you right okay so
night and then I don't have anything cuz
I don't know um read that again the
bishop and the Queen aren't next to each
other the Queen and the rook were
opposite each other too but I don't know
where the rook is you don't even have
the rook yet I don't think no but I just
have a queen and it came so I could just
put them in here for now but I don't
know where they go yet yeah
so you need the rook and the bishop oh
wait I just realized something
the rook and the knight are on the same
wall the bishop and the Queen are next
to each other the Queen and the rook
were opposite of each other so if the
Queen and the rook are opposite each
other then the Queen has to be in the
middle do you know what I mean mm-hmm
because it's the only one that has an
opposite no no they all have an opposite
but oh I see her yeah yeah according to
the know it's the only one that has an
opposite that's what I thought yeah cuz
this these have opposites already this
is the only one that has a free opposite
no no no oh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
so the bishop is what the bishop and the
Queen aren't next to each other and the
Queen and the rook were opposite each
other too so I just need to figure out
so the bishop should be over here cuz it
wasn't next to the Queen mm-hmm I'm
amazing and then that would mean that
the King stops and that would mean that
the king is over here and that would
mean that the bishop is there and then
the only thing that would change this is
if I got the order wrong and the Queen
is on the other side of the wall
but everything else makes sense
according to
details they said the Queen shouldn't be
on the same wall as something else right
yeah the Queen and the rook Bishop and
the Queen are not next to each other uh
did I make them next we Cho no that's
the what the King right yes okay so this
is right
this fits all the rules yeah you just
need to find the rough piece Swick
alright so where the [ __ ] I'm going but
I have we got two more plugs like you
said and I have this tool keep that yeah
I have a sewer key keep that and I have
to full heat three full heels I probably
don't need all of them yeah what you
don't need all three I don't need all
three okay so I'll get rid of the spray
cuz it's the least valuable um I don't
have a lot of ammo here I have a little
bit of submachine gun I have this sick
ass spark shot I have one Grenada and I
have fancy bullets
what's your thumb I would bring do you
have leftover magnum rounds in your
inventory Magnum so yeah now that you've
upgraded that first handgun it's pretty
much your Magnum now okay I don't think
I have any magnum rounds but I have all
sorts of gun powder can I use any of
this gun powder to make uh a magnum I
don't think so
I have more Sun machine gun ammo which I
gum gum ammo which I'm tempted to take
because I have such little ammo oh no
high-powered rounds are for the Magnum
down one oh I wouldn't even bring that
right now okay so should I get rid of
that gun then I mean yes store that gun
for now and then take out the submachine
Emma yeah sure
um but you didn't store the Magnum I was
thinking strong yes thank you a lot to
songs stuck in my head oh I can't
well I'll go through this really quickly
ah
all right oh where am I going
I'm good question what is your what's
your map doing looking like oh yeah
let's let's let's check that map hey um
I'm looking for one more plug I have
have I not been down here is this locked
this must be a lot that's that's the
door the plug unlocks oh that makes
sense
um funny cuz plugs usually lock doors
you hear that yeah what is that I don't
know there's like some sorry I have no
idea
should I be going to these waterways
that looks like that that door you need
so I'm pretty sure you need to use that
crank handle soon okay yeah we can go
explore yeah just go in that general
direction what general direction
you can't no no no the door you're left
I ain't going this way because that's
where those gross things were oh yeah
you're going back into the sewers but I
don't want to but you have to okay yes I
did you go onto the catwalk over there
to the right like around all the way
here yeah yes I will go again
oh yeah that's where the safe was with
writing on the side correct the writing
was like on the [ __ ] safe not too
shabby
and I don't think there was anything
else and we killed this man okay then
there was two ways to go down this door
which leads to the sewers and this way
which I don't think I've investigated
too much so we could look at it I need
it I need a wristband and there's really
nothing around here right that I'm aware
of I guess to the door way to the left
oh my god sometimes I swear I see stuff
but it's nothing I'm just like
everything just looks at evil doesn't it
or like a shadow or like that could kill
me like you see how looking down it's
because I swear I see something in the
water right there but it's just a
reflection of a pipe I think it's just a
reflection but it's obvious like it
seems so reasonable it's like all meant
to scare you like when they put that
[ __ ] mannequin shadow in earlier just
to be rude Arcade Fire what do you like
Arcade Fire oh uh yeah I've heard a
couple of their tracks they're tunes I
think I've seen them live but it was not
on purpose
yeah should have been I like him yeah um
isn't there like eight people in their
band uh at that times yeah yeah I saw
them and there were so many people and I
remember vividly there was like this
girl and she would play like a guitar
and then she like took out an accordion
and then she like played drums and I was
like you go girl cuz she just knew she
knew so much stuff and I was really
impressed
but so I think it's a while ago that
bands been around for a really long time
uh what am i doing I think you're going
down there maybe you have to go a
grenade aah
Oh green add huh
follow the poop river and thence you'll
find your boat do you hear that yeah is
it just the sound of poop I think so
my disgusted face
how's my tongue stick out but I feel
like that's inappropriate in like a poop
scenario yeah II thought [ __ ] what's up
with this whole I don't know that makes
me uncomfortable the word hole or that
hole oh that's specific trap forever
so this goes back to where we were um
open your app quick what's that noise
I don't know oh there's a work room lift
what's up with that is it broken
is that where I came from no I don't
think so you might be able to use a key
there I don't [ __ ] remember half the
[ __ ] you know no pun intended I just
don't remember I have no idea what it is
I don't think you saw you either you
just hanging out
oh I think that's the way you need to go
too
I don't want to Shareen it'll be safe we
discussed this he's a spud gun on him
what use the spark gun on him he sent
out his little minion children
where this
[ __ ] is it
aha
suck on that one we did it I think
there's a crank handle in that little
doorway I've been mistaken several times
before here yeah that's okay those spark
plugs are pretty valuable those what
plugs spark plugs Oh
where do they called spark shots yeah
what were you what did you think I said
Oh butt plug you're supposed to be
embarrassed when I ask you not riffing
right now I'm talking to the second Nick
very seriously
there better not be any dogs in here I
do not be any skeletons in your closet
why is she so upset
Oh smells like trash Oh
Magnum breath stinks in here it stinks
it stinks it stink
what is that from uh Simpsons
oh that guy's [ __ ] super alive what I
actually changed guns oh my god okay you
should be dead you handled that well
shut up the national treasure quote ooh
[Laughter]
hang on Emma written Alice slaps what's
that noise
that was the sound of a tool chest
falling down the stairs fool filum oh
that that's important to keep that okay
well I don't know like wouldn't but ooh
more inventory I Spy and him in the hip
pack oh I see it
Wow my [ __ ] mistake what do you mean
no I call it a hip pack it's a hip pouch
oh it's not as bad as the sparkplug
accident
yeah leaky spark Oh kiss you there yes
oh he's so fast so he's really speedy
isn't he
hold still their heads swinging around
damn it I feel as if you would be better
off opening the door and then shooting
them but there's two it's so satisfying
when you do it though oh one of them
fell down he tried bad ground and he's
just died and you're gonna miss that he
tried to attack me tell me what
it's a push door not a pull you big dumb
idiot oh wait no it is a push door yeah
the other guy dad I don't know
but I hope you can beat me with one
friggin arm
I think so
yeah whoa
this is the worst yeah he's dead what
about this one I just go oh no there's
so many it's kind of chubby not that
that's a problem just where'd he go
there's a plan Jesus yeah he disappeared
into fat air alright here we go
rook that's the last one
five ring wait what's going on boss
eight boss fight' bought no I'm just
kidding it just raises that you can put
it back in and lower it [ __ ] sounds
dramatic I was making it sound oh
actually yes okay that door um I believe
you can open that door to your all to
the right of the screen with the key of
F okay you mean the training facility
training facility look at all these
dongle oh my god we'll get I did not
bring the dongle alright
I like holes
alright macGruber use the key don't tell
me what to do you can't tell me what to
do
discard that [ __ ] oh no it's not no no
you can use it again um okay what goes
IE yeah we doing well you know what do
you say hey are we going yeah what you
know what'd he say
nice
Laure z oh I see s ZF SDF
SCF
no I would not have done that
instinctively like she saw it before I
did um
do I have any unfinished business in the
previous place yeah trying to thank you
should the stairs here what's up with
that yes that's the work the workers
break room here now you can bring the
dongle back later for a weapon upgrade
once you go up the elegant elevator but
should i do first i only got two slots
left i would go i wouldn't go up there
yet
but is there uh there's nothing here
lock
yeah the sec f is for a combination lock
i'm assuming right that has to be so um
it's not here but i'm sure it's quite
close out so you got the rook plug there
all right still go back out yeah and
then they have you gone to your left yet
no or my nor my right i try there yeah
it this way that's probably some down
those crates there's [ __ ] something
on everything there's nothing there's
never anything on anything i never get a
million dollars oh that guy isn't us why
uniform he looks like hunk he's uh don't
waste a bullet on just walk by him why
he's going to get up he might not yes he
will
who knows so I should definitely waste a
bullet I don't want to get caught in a
stairwell with him
haha someone's sleepy he's [ __ ] super
alive let's go he hasn't woken up yeah
you just touched them but I don't want
to jump down there because then I'm
gonna get stuck down there it's not jump
down it's the stairs I don't wanna get
stuck down there can't you can go back
upstairs I think they're just baiting
you into being afraid
obviously the fallen well the clemency
there's nothing wrong with shooting
people yes there is you're wasting
bullets dad
I disagree
zero regret wake up
[ __ ] [ __ ] thank you
Oh a tape we saw where to play that
isn't a safe room right get up
you ass I hate you did you say there she
say that I hate you I said yeah I'm
flattered that you think we sound alike
like what's down there and sewers get up
you're in the hot seat
zombie I where am I
I've never been here before
alright so should I go left or right
right is a dead end
why are you laughing what's funny cousin
I don't doesn't matter you could go left
and then it looks like it will connect
you to somewhere you have been I don't
know go both ways we can figure it out
guide my main objective right now is to
get that rook plug but obviously picking
it back up to you
oh no wait
and it
I knew it I knew it I knew it
where's the thigh I don't think you can
worry about it
don't ya yeah
what do you agree with what I'm doing
yeah yeah
worry about the little guys
ah [ __ ] you got him yeah you Chris it's
still breathing I exploded his eyeball
I'm like pretty much out of ammo hearing
now you're fine
yeah don't sway
because I don't have a gun to use these
bullets no I know you're fine
is this where I was before god I have no
idea where I want to go should I check
out this square first before I take this
tunnel like should I check out over yawn
yeah yeah
Oh No
I feel a little
exposed in here right now oh this was
the place I know where I am okay so now
you have the shortcut I think you can
now get the rook plug yrt hot oh you
mean like put it in oh you do already
have don't worry
back up here you got the rook you got
the six plug your set I will say that
should based on my memory
once you plug in you should get the USB
dongle and go back to that employee
elevator okay is that a weapon upgrade
yeah I also feel like in general so like
I never went here so there's a lot still
to do I'm fairly certain that goes to
the other side of the rook bridge but
yes definitely worth checking out should
I do that I was just like what the plug
in just to get rid of it okay I was also
gonna save big save the rook should go
in the middle if it doesn't I know how
to solve it
where the [ __ ] is the rook there it is
how do I know if it's oh it's wrong okay
then so I know I know it's wrong so
these are opposite I think
that's a yeah because we knew according
to my knowledge that those had to be
there which means these have to switch
to right
something like that I just to read the
restrictions again the rook and the
knight are on the same wall check that
just make sure they're on the same wall
okay so that's the night
that's the rook the Queen and the rook
we're opposite to enos in the right spot
already that's the King right there the
bishop and the Queen aren't next to each
other yeah no I think they are so I just
have to switch that then that is the
bishop right there okay so I just switch
that needs to go where the king is and
then bring the King over here yup yup
yup yup
nope
this guy
okay cool
all right sherry on my way I'm gonna
save your saving also tape yeah dad yeah
tapes are very Resident Evil 7 yeah
Home Video found footage
hence g-virus was spread she speaks for
us all really cool what a progress so
far yeah cool
so oh let's put some stuff away I'm
actually fairly full might be worth
storing the submachine gun and taking
your handgun okay I wouldn't take those
magnum rounds right now put the magnums
back yeah do I need this Grenada I
wouldn't say you need the roll of film
because you can if you're gonna go if
you're gonna use it the save box in the
film room is right next to it the
darkroom um I don't even think you need
both of those uh get rid of that gun
powder I'd say okay map cuz now you want
to go to oh I'm not gonna go down there
no not yet that'll trigger like Oh like
a scene I mean I think you could and
you'd be fine
my brother do the things that I should
do unless yeah open your app again so I
haven't done this I mean yeah but you
also want to go to Oh down to the bottom
no you want to great stop her updating I
can't read that website oh my god George
oh no that's where we were that's where
the spark tube was II so the elevators
past the that's the behind that locker
secret door you found right right we
haven't done that yet
trying to figure out how to get you
might yeah you might as well just go
investigate that lower walkway you saw
okay so that's going like literally back
the way I came so I'll go back through
this room under here yeah in the
treatment wait oh okay never right yeah
yeah sorry just room yes
no I saw that yet I saw the unexplored
part of the map but that's where you're
going now that you've um if I if I come
across Noah's eyeball dudes I really
don't have the ammo to take care of him
Oh dodged him yeah yeah you couldn't get
back to the lower walkway really easily
through that circular room at the bottom
of the stairs to the right right here
yeah here right so time up yeesh yeah
cuz there's what you get down there
there's a one of the doorways leads
right to the walkway okay [ __ ] twitch
did you see it they always twitch stop
trying to plug your [ __ ] company I
think that's do you see him twitch I
just see it did he just do a game spot
nobody ever says that your SEO sucks
actually your SEO is really good totally
game spot at her ah ha ha ha no actually
it's bad because everybody always thinks
it's game stop right yeah I get that all
the time so this is where I was I think
bring up your map I'm gonna go over a
walkway that's the gate is that it's
dick bring up your map yeah thank you um
yeah and I get in here you have but I
don't think you found anything I haven't
been in here
yes oh okay so as Leon that you slide
down that waterfall at one point I don't
know what's that all right I remember
yeah I mean go investigate it I just
feel like there's nothing good down here
there's at least an item I'd say and you
can outrun a monster at this point look
at file ID I want to well you're on the
hot bait huh there you go
hand goon
cool it's blue I'm [ __ ] off right now
all right and I want to take a left and
go to the lower waterway and it's also
red so there's something
oh great
okay thanks you have a lot of Magnum era
or I mean like a decent nine or 12 so
now you want to go I can't even see them
but no keep them rabble over think we
want to go to the elevator right yeah go
up over to the right yeah it's there
[ __ ]
it would also I think there's an item in
the water injection chamber that you I
think there's stuff there that you could
get if you brought that you might as
well yeah you also need the dongles and
you should also bring the rook plug with
you okay because the you need to in
order to get to the water and check some
chamber there is a bridge you need to
lower by inserting the brook plug so
we'll just go home
yeah yes to get the dongle in the rook
plug from the wall yep yeah and you
could if you wanted to once you're back
in the
you could you checked the roll film
actually we should do that I know that
their place to check the roll of film in
the same room no it's only in that one
darkroom we should go back those the two
things they get it shows you hiding
places for things oh all right
it took me forever to find a second one
when I was playing the remake initially
[Music]
no yeah yeah yeah
Castle oh that didn't close the door all
right cool it wouldn't matter um okay so
now get the dongle from the box dongle I
almost forgot and you definitely need
the valve
hi all right so dongle valve rook I only
have twenty six bullets thirty bullets a
grenade a grenade you could savor now if
you wanted to just to be safe but I
think you're fine items I mean it
doesn't you know my motto save often and
save well alright let's [ __ ] off
alright so we want to go where are we
going a good question I yeah through
there for sure you're getting back to
the workers training facility I'm
turning member it's through the lower
walkway I remember go back to the walk
where you're just in where you're
checking for items I believe and then
you're gonna go through the right fork
they didn't go through I remember okay
yeah that goes home cuz I came in
through the poop chute I maybe double
check the mattress tag damnit twitch
again it's like here right or something
yeah you gotta go go up a level maybe
two levels yeah go up one more you're
going to they're trying to you get no
sorry yeah the yeah okay the stairs to
the right up southeast of your cursor
right yeah you're getting there okay so
good now level yeah you're going there
right there which is upper waterway
where are you right now
lower waterway you want to get to the
upper waterway so no I wouldn't go down
there yet then the way I came isn't it
this place is so confusing they do this
on purpose yeah yeah yeah yeah
shut up that's also very home alone
right Mondrian I made my family
disappear you are almost there
I take a right and then to the stairs
yeah
I bake my mommy eat a pear I don't want
you to say it in the other way he says
uh you know what I mean you know what I
mean what do you know like this
I made my mommy eat a pear yeah oh I see
yeah it's really sexual so Brooke plug
and across and I think you can use the
key that you have any inventory on that
door across there which one should i do
first it has to be the rook right now
that'll lower it
key um what door across so you do this
area first as Leon I think you need the
key on that Oh what the [ __ ] is that uh
uh to the left
she's the key to what yeah but what's
that the move across that bridge would
come he can also ditch that key now I
believe yeah I made my mom eat her stop
I've got a gun
nobody bad ooh ooh God nice large okay
this area is blue
well that was nice okay
now down this hellhole do I have to you
know but might as well
I watched free solo the other night that
movies nuts I heard I heard it I mean it
obviously won the Best Documentary at
the Oscar which is whatever but like I
knew who Alex Honnold was he was in New
York recently and he decided to just
scale the side of this building in
Jersey City for like free sit without a
rope or anything he told the building
manager ahead of time and he did it like
at 7:00 in the morning or something and
he had to go in through this family's
like living room cuz he like he got like
three-quarters the way up he's like yeah
I guess I'm done should I even kill this
guy do I even need to come down here no
not really blue yeah I don't think you
need to like what's in here that I would
even come down here we go
yes like what
like this guy can't like there's no need
for me to go down there right right um
just go get the truck plug and get out
of there
it was worth it for the Gunpowder I'd
say actually you could probably believe
the ruff plug for now yeah I don't worry
about that don't fill up space oh yeah
you're coming you literally have to come
back through here through the elevator
all right just yeah you could take it so
you remember it I have to come back here
yeah because you haven't gone through
the actual plug the door that the plug
is open yet we're going up to the police
station right now to use the film and
the dongle right
why does it go up at all I don't know
[ __ ] fines you should I come in here
yeah that's right up the elevator
he's the guy gonna be there with the hat
no I remember william birkin tore him
apart yeah I remember have a gun there
anything on those barrels am i oh magnum
rounds Jesus what is going on
was that you oh gosh yeah well what yeah
but there's someone here
oh this place is right for death you
have to tell me if you're here okay
dongle right to your left the glass case
use the dongle on here yeah what a
specific thing I know it's dumb what is
[ __ ] going on uh yeah use the dongle
yeah I did
oh you sorry you got a close the USB
part oh I'm so dumb yeah wait like you
examine it and then rotate it and press
X it's crazy it even fits like they
should just been like it didn't fit I
know it's dumb
no I mean uh yeah I guess you can do
that a suppressor is that for my current
gun or for the other gun um it'll tell
you do I need this do I need the dog I
don't think so you could take it in case
you're going back to the BEM q11 is the
another gun right yeah I believe so yeah
okay now what you could take the dongle
a few watches for posterity sake is
there any reason cuz it takes up a
you're gonna discard it if you want I
mean oh yeah let's go back up and then
look at that roll of film for the up
these stairs
yeah this brings you back up to the
police station his eyes that's nice
mm-hmm you're in that like desk room but
now you have the valve so you can or
sorry the crank handle so you can open
the belt I want to go up the stairs or
what's this oh you already went there a
long time ago there's nothing you this
is where you fought sort of working okay
oh what a labyrinth hey
I remember this
I'm as well discard the bat right
thoughts you probably only need one
healing thing and you don't need the
brook plug now you can get down the way
back down
don't use the valve on that just think
that's the last time you use the valve
oh no it's not you use it upstairs
unlike second okay
I'll keep it just for anxiety safe yeah
now back to the dark room to see those
hiding spots so take a yeah after there
here yeah and then to the other side of
the office and then you're pretty much
there sort of dark room okay so out here
anyway they're a [ __ ] liquor in this
uh yeah but you can avoid them shut the
[ __ ] up
what are you saying since when just just
go um you guys they go right when you
come out of here my god you Matt yeah
take a right and then yeah down that
hallway a lot of blood
it's my blood
hey you go walk faster I don't think
that he's here there's that idiot
is this a safe space yeah I don't think
you have them Oh dummy
all right well I'm really glad this is a
safe room I got here and I needed that
thing I would have been pissed I
wouldn't know what that happened you
guys have don't you sit there now you've
led me astray I know we're both these
are so you don't to pay too much
attention the top one is the stars
office the leaders it's Wesker's desk
the bottom one is the press room which
[ __ ] my face I didn't mean to say that
to get you to get the press room we have
to go through that horror hell hallway
go the quick way now open the map I
think we can okay so the when you go
I think it's upstairs actually go up yes
stars office that's we're pretty much
near the room to the left of that
exclamation point is where one of them
is the other one I think it's go down
one more floor again sorry it is in the
press room yeah to the east so that's
also pretty easy to get to we should
probably focus on the stars just go
upstairs and then around the bathroom
that long roof and that guy can't come
and kill me I think he's dead at this
point yeah you're fine never forget
[ __ ] you
he's the main nemesis second for you
also another one up taking that a long
way around yeah uh actually could you go
through the library at this point I it's
the same distance either way
actually no you couldn't go through the
library anyway yeah just keep going this
way like there I know sorry a second
second floor go back don't hear yeah to
the right
it's too thick it's sitting everywhere
they had to clean teeth so I'm going all
the way down I don't know it's just it's
too late
yeah it's in there it's like top drawer
whatever I don't know do you not get the
X unless you see those like this yeah
yeah
you've looked there before come on gimme
gimme gimme gimme
that's also for the submachine gun for
the submachine gun yeah all right and
now you want to do the other one so easy
yeah it'll be the press room on the east
so you're on the other side of the
building
oh should I just go through the library
or no yeah go back to the main hall and
then just transfer over go downstairs
and then yeah so left
I just feel like there this hallway is
legitimately clear I think you killed
the liquor I mean you definitely killed
that liquor but you think an animal with
an exposed brain would be more
vulnerable that's how they get you
there's also gunpowder downstairs that
we couldn't fit last time yeah I just
threw that door to the right to the main
hall yeah and then downstairs yeah this
place is a lot less scary without those
[ __ ] running around oh look at that
guy her ex yeah so just go down and then
you're gonna go through that first door
you go down yeah you're gonna go first
or you had to crawl through kind of
directly opposite of where you are now
so here yeah and then follow this
hallway to the left
I don't think anyways here really yeah
down there isn't this the whole way of
death no that's the west side you don't
have to go there thank God there's
definitely somebody in here
it's no wait
oh yeah it's fall out yeah press room
oh [ __ ] look he's not good he's not
gonna do anything just go and then
you're going you're checking the cabinet
the boom box to the left ish like in the
back [ __ ] ooh all right what should I do
here the last hiding spots back left
corner but if you he's if you're not
like a growing ham there's no reason to
fight him
the quiet spot ammo
which is valuable I'm just gonna [ __ ]
off
yeah that guy's not worth I think it's
worth getting that gunpowder and that
might actually be a good end of the
episode we knocked oh yeah [ __ ] I'm
trying to member hi oh that's the room
that has flare has to go through oh no I
don't know if that's worth it that's the
hell hollow um I mean you could try on
open the map one more time no you could
go through the West office and then you
know yeah you could try that's where I
think the liquor would be that way if
anything if you sense any danger it's
not worth it but if not then go for it
do not be afraid to like bail at a
moment's notice because I that is like
the worst part of the map that I have
helped you create it's and then into the
hallway and then through that yeah I
don't know we'll see I'm this whole
episodes been good you haven't healed
yeah it was in here this is where that
[ __ ] of a battle happened yes sir
through that door like take a let's take
a right
yeah that one and then a but there might
be a liquor in here did you go through
there there's gunpowder the back yeah on
the copy machine who left this gunpowder
on the copy machine we've talked about
this sweet okay that was a fruitful
visit back to the RCD episode we'll go
back down or we could just do that now
yeah you could I'm not any brush um
definitely save once more cuz a lot of
stuff is about to happen but but say
when you get back down to sewers but
just go back down the sewers through the
main hall okay no no oh oh yeah are you
right yeah I'm yeah all right doesn't
the West sorry it doesn't the main hall
have an easy way to get there now yeah
it's the door near where Marvin so
you're left right there yeah you'll end
up back in the workers room and then you
could stock up right now is the same
book so I got a knife which is great
because I didn't have one for a really
long time oh I could make my gun
fancier now cuz I have all those items
it also combines some ammo you should
try to make submachine gun ammo if you
have it don't I don't don't worry about
taking your Magnum right now well I was
just gonna do the mixing you don't have
any Magnum parts both both parts you got
work for the submachine gun
Oh ones the compensator whatever it is
they call it suppressor but it's acts
like a compensator the other ones an
extended mag which blends where
compensators
pretty much that's why I use them um
where the [ __ ] is the compensator you
arty that's a new inventory it's like
you have both oh I do I do
the eat old cartridge you got is spark
shot
see it alright so this is for the spark
shot
no no [ __ ] I'm dumb heart of Sparta
that's just a mo yeah it's just a mo mmm
but the ones the left of that is for the
submachine gun okay so combined with the
submachine gun which is this and then
this also goes to this yeah okay okay
stop machine you should I don't know how
but here hover over at gunpowder's I got
standard grade it creates handgun ammo
I've got high grade but combined with
gunpowder to make acid rounds or two of
these to make machine gun ammo but I
don't have two of them I actually think
you're set for now at the very least
store that gunpowder you have and the
Magnum sort of that I don't you know for
weapons yeah I guess so
you got the ammo for the spark shot your
I think you're set you got eight spark
you have one that's equipped right now I
would actually equip your knife um I
think you're set
do you have a green herb them in your
yeah I have three yeah I would use one
just to get up to full health so you
don't throw waste that and now I would
just wait to save until you get back
down to the spark plug room or sorry the
plug from and that's all the way back
down yeah
town you're just pretty much don't do
the door
we're going downtown we like running
around downtown everything's cool when
you're downtown we have to go down in
towner
even further cheese
next week I go to San Francisco why I
thought you in a pax I'm doing pax to my
go to San Francisco
nice twitches these things called
ambassadors they're like really good
streamers that are also like we call
them ambassadors because they like yeah
should I put the rough backer no I don't
even know if you know no no I'm just go
through that door though
what door other way this what day yeah
anyway I'm going to like shoot some
footage of them and help hype up
twitchcon Europe that's why that's what
I'm doing
what am i doing in here you're just
going back to the save room yeah take
that down that goes down I guess uh I
wouldn't even be faster you buy the
other way maybe I don't know I don't
actually don't know how and this looks
like it goes up nope that goes down down
yeah I think you just go down yourself
oh there you go yeah so you're going go
on am I going this way go up on your map
no I think you want to go up or walkway
cuz we want to go here yeah yeah go down
again lower water way to the right
Oh use the stairs it's either one I
think either one will get you there
this is the slower way I don't know how
to do it the faster I don't it would
have been the go up again one more time
yeah good and go up one more time cuz
like why would I have taken that down
been there and then you go oh yeah so
that go down yeah
actually just take the elevator back up
I know where to go it's it's a bit of a
labyrinth but I think that's going
roundabout yeah
Oh his butt was definitely twitching
100% hips butt is a twitch ambassador
ambassador all right it's like this way
right
yes am ask the door
I'm disparaging twitch now and I'm just
kidding
lovely can't hurt us but she's nice
she's gonna pledge water she walks like
she's on the set of Aladdin wait
hi it's so easy to get turned around you
wanted to go up oh this step bridge
where you always see the dude right
under it yeah this is the shutup bridge
shut up and then we go up there's
probably a faster way to do it but this
is the way I've learned to do it and I
know no better
we never learned what to do with those
letters isn't that odd there's a lot how
many I just don't know where alright we
did it and we go down there next time
yeah I'm just saved
good job all yeah I don't know it's
always in this scene that office I don't
so I don't record in the Giant Bomb
office anymore because the mic here is
much better it's not a USB mic the
camera is much better and it's already
set up for Skype so yeah it works out
but there's also a ball down this path
again you don't have to I'm lonely
without my little idiot thanks for
watching we'll see you guys again mate
hey just fade when I was riffing count
when I was Kent Ken riffey junior